before I start speaking about CSS
variable secrets I feel I should
introduce myself a bit so hola soy
Aliyah this is pretty much all the
Spanish I know so the rest of the talk
is gonna be in English sorry about that
and here's a little-known fact about me
I'm originally from Greece and
specifically from the island of Lesbos
which technically makes me
geographically lesbian one of the very
few you ever made you might have used
some of my stuff I like making them I'm
an invited expert in the CSS working
group so if you have any questions about
standards and the CSS working group and
all that you can either ask me after the
talk or find me anywhere at the
conference I'll be here the whole day my
day job is a little odd for the last
three years I've been exploring academia
I'm a researcher at MIT we're trying to
make web programming easier and more
accessible to more people you might have
heard about our project Malvo which is
extending HTML to describe web
applications and I wrote a book if you
have it I can sign it just don't be
afraid to speak to me to come find me
I'll sign it so CSS variables when many
people when they hear of CSS variables
they wonder what is there to talk about
I mean there isn't that much really and
that's because when they think of CSS
variables they imagine of something like
they think of something like this how
many of you have think of have used sass
or less variables almost everybody
excellent this talk is not about them
nope this talk is about something much
better something that's available in all
your browsers and that can do so much
more than preprocessor variables so
probably the very first variable a
little history here probably the very
first variable we ever got in CSS was
current color and it came from SVG a
long time ago it's supported everywhere
even 99 how many of you have heard of
current color most of you excellent
so as you might know current color
always corresponds to the value of the
color property so you can change the
color and it chases everywhere so I'm
using it in the CSS gradient here it
changes in the gradient as well it's
useful but a bit limited so CSS
variables also called custom properties
are a generalization of this concept
they are defined with a double dash in
the beginning you might think that this
is very weird and kind of clumsy I agree
with you the double dash actually comes
from the idea that these custom
properties are like a prefixed property
with an empty prefix remember those -
WebKit - so here the prefix is empty
there is no WebKit or most part it's
just an empty prefix and you use them
with the VAR function like this and I
can do this here too and I can keep
changing it and it works the same way as
it did before you might be wondering so
okay works the same way as it did before
so what did we do here what's what's the
point but this is not just about colors
I can take this 20 pixels here and turn
it into another variable corner size or
corner for short and I can give it a
value of 20 and you can see it here I
can now change this property
individually I don't need to change the
entire gradient and you might be
thinking especially those of you that
have used less and sass okay what's the
point I can do that in Lesson sass but
can you do this in Lesson sass the CSS
variables can be used anywhere you could
even change this with JavaScript and
we're gonna see some examples of this at
the end so this is the main difference
of CSS variables over pre-processors
they're dynamic they're live you can
change them at any point even after your
page loads you might have noticed that
when I cop when I cut and copied when I
cut and paste this corner declaration I
lost my corners and that's because I
have not defined a default value
I can't however I can do it as the
second argument of the VAR function
and now if I have no corner property to
find it uses that default value I can
still define my own and this second
argument is called the fallback
so our first takeaway is that CSS
variables work just like normal CSS
properties take a look for a bit at this
small HTML structure it's two dips a one
has a class of block one the other one
has a class of block two and they each
have a div inside them we're going to be
using the structure to demonstrate
various things throughout the talk so
notice that here have defined the
outline function property as the value
of the outline variable everywhere on
every element and I've only defined a
value for the outline variable on block
1 do you notice anything you might
expect that only block 1 should get an
outline because that's the only one with
an outline property defined let me
remind you this is the structure however
its child also gets an outline the div
inside it also gets an outline why is
that it's because custom properties also
inherit by default you can check however
to change this if you go to the
universal selector and you define your
variable as initial that cancels
inheritance why does that why does that
work because when you target an element
directly even with us even with a rule
that has zero specificity like the star
selector it still has higher precedence
than something inherited so we're
basically saying here that if if an
element doesn't have a value for the
outline variable directly then just set
it to initial initial is a keyword by
the way that works in every CSS property
including custom ones and it just means
the initial value that this has if if
there was no rule setting it of course I
can still explicitly inherit on a
case-by-case basis
I could go here and say inherit and I
still get the same behavior but when I
changed this to block two I don't
so the second takeaway is that CSS
variables are inherited properties not
just any property not just like any
properties but you can change that so we
get the best of both worlds so some of
you might be thinking at this point of
like things you could do with CSS
variables possibly things you did with
sass or less in the past that maybe you
can move to CSS variables or even things
that you couldn't do with less and sass
that you could do with CSS variables so
you might consider okay so I have this
folder with all my images it would be
kind of cool if I could just store the
file name of the image in a variable and
just use that so you might try to do
something like this let's say an image
variable like that and we might be
thinking how can we put them next to
each other ah we've seen something like
that in the content property so we try
something like this like putting the
strings next to each other it doesn't
work why doesn't it work it doesn't work
because CSS doesn't really have
concatenation you cannot really put two
strings together we can only do that in
the content property and that's because
the content property is defined like
that it's not a CSS wide thing
eventually we're gonna get away to do to
do string concatenation probably through
a function or something but we don't
right now there is no way to put two
strings together so I'm our next attempt
it might be just because we're trying
things out to do this and it should work
right we've seen CSS variables used
inside a function like in the very
beginning of this talk I used one in
radial gradient so why is this not
working this doesn't make sense and you
would be right if you're puzzled it
doesn't make sense
it's a CSS bug it's only in this
function where variables are not
supported only in the URL function the
reason is that the URL function is the
first function we ever got in CSS so it
has some really weird parsing rules you
can use it with or without quotes and
since you can use it both with and
without quotes it has to try to parse
everything inside it
a URL if you're not using quotes so it
basically considers all of this until
the first parentheses a URL and since it
doesn't make sense as the URL and
doesn't resolve to anything you get
nothing
so our first attempt our third attempt
might be to also include the URL
function just because we're desperate at
this point and of course this will work
but it's kind of useless so to sum up we
cannot concatenate because that's a CSS
limitation we cannot use variables in
URL because that's a CSS bug that also
means no generating data your eyes like
a really cool use case for variables
would be generating like dáil SVG data
your eyes via variables I think that
would enable so many things sadly we
can't do it in the third case which
works is if you use the entire URL in a
variable as a variable it didn't work
until recently we couldn't decide how to
resolve the URL if they're in separate
style sheets but now it does
so the third takeaway is that CSS
variables plus URL function equals
chocolate ice cream some more WTF
because this is CSS after all so you
expect them I imagine so if you use an
empty value like if if you're if the
value of your CSS variables empty that's
invalid no surprises there right however
if the value of your CSS variable is an
is a space character that's valid and
the value of the variable is a space
character which is unlike any other CSS
property also upper case pool and lower
case for different variables which is
also unlike every other CSS property but
there you have it so I showed you
quickly in the beginning that the second
argument of the VAR function is the
fallback and I know that some of you
must have been wondering why do we need
a space
a special fallback mechanism we have a
fallback mechanism you know the C in CSS
it means cascade why can't we just use
the Cascade as a fallback you know how
we usually just have two declarations
and if the browser doesn't understand
the second one we get the first or if
the second one is invalid we get the
first and so on and this this works in
in CSS variables as well it works just
fine if the browser doesn't understand
variables so in this case if the browser
doesn't understand variables what do you
expect to get read write and read we get
and so the purpose of this fallback is
not to define what happens if the
browser doesn't understand variables
because then it wouldn't understand the
full but either it's to define what
happens if the variable is not set
if you've defined your style and it uses
variables and there is no value like
these variables are set to their initial
value and in that case if accent color
is not set you get orange which is our
fallback here and of course if accent
color is set to a specific color you get
that color so here's a question what do
you expect to get if accent color is
indeed set but it's set to something
that doesn't make sense for background
like 42 degrees raise your hands if you
expect to get red very few hands good by
the time we get there the Browse browser
has thrown away any previous
declarations it doesn't even know there
was ever a red there all it has is our
second VAR declaration raise your hands
if you think it's gonna be orange a lot
more hands this is a reasonable
assumption but no orange is this
fallback is only if the variable has not
been set if it has been set then we then
the fallback is not used what else do
you think it might be shout it if you
have an idea of what like what color it
could be
someone said transparent and yes that is
correct it's gonna be transparent and
the reason is that when we defined
variables we introduced this new concept
in CSS that didn't exist before called
invalided computed value time so what
does this mean it means that when since
when we get there we cannot fall back to
any previous declarations like we can't
for any other invalid value we needed to
come up with something different to make
variables possible we couldn't just say
we couldn't just say okay the browser
has to reparse the entire CSS again that
wouldn't work that would be extremely
slow so we had to come up with some
other kind of behavior and invalid that
computed value times this behavior it
means if if this computed value doesn't
make sense
after you substituted all the variables
just fall back to your initial value and
for background this is none non
transparent and stuff so you basically
get a transparent background you would
you get the same thing that you would
get if you use background initial so the
first takeaway is that invalided
computed value time is initial and you
might even though this concept was
introduced for variables you might start
seeing it in other places in CSS like
calc for example could benefit from it
we'll see how shortly another thing
about these fall backs is that you can
daisy-chain them you don't just have to
provide the fixed value you could
provide another variable as a fallback
and another variable here the fallback
of color one is color 2 and the fallback
of color 2 is color 3 in the fallback of
color 3 is red so how many of you have
used like Java Script or any other
programming language that has like an
order of operations a few hands I would
say about 30% maybe so those of you
especially those of you that are
familiar with these languages you might
think that in this case for example you
have two divs
the first one that says CSS is awesome
the second one is the one that's
inverted and it has the class of
declarative I can actually show you the
HTML it's here and let's say we want the
second one to be 1m taller than the
first one so here we've decided a size
for both depths and we've set the height
to the size and you might be thinking
okay so if I want the second one to be a
1 I'm taller than the first one I could
do something like this we can get the
value of size and add 1m and then to our
surprise nothing works anymore it's the
same as if we didn't have a height at a
height property at all
see if I comment the Scheldt the height
and the black div doesn't change why why
is that why did that happen the reason
is that CSS is the clarity just like the
black Dave tells you it's it's not
imperative like other programming
languages with which have an order of
operations where size could have this
value and then you add one to it and it
has a different value there is no time
there's no time line there's no it has
this variable used to have this value
but now it has this one the only the
only such thing could be if you change
it with a pseudo class or something but
for the same rule for the same selector
it always has the same value so this
wouldn't work what would work of course
would be if you did this so the fifth
takeaway is that cycles make variables
at invalided computed value time this is
what's happening there the reason that
height reset the reason that that height
basically became as if we weren't
setting it to anything is because height
basically became equivalent to initial
to its initial value because it became
invalid the computed value time and it's
it's basically a domino of invalid at
computed value time because we have this
value size but because we have a cycle
here size refers to itself and we can
also have cycles if like a refers to B
and B refers to a there can be cycles of
all sizes
so size becomes equivalent to initial so
because we're using we're setting height
based on size that also becomes its
initial value because size doesn't have
the size doesn't have a value at this
point so here is a little bit a little
question again it's very very similar to
what I asked you before except I've
inserted a line the line I've inserted
is this this did not exist before the
rest of it is exactly the same as the
previous question accent color is set to
42 degrees and then background red and
background var accent color orange so
what do you expect to happen here what
color do you expect to get I here
transparent anyone else any other ideas
so those of you that said orange are
correct it is orange so can you think
why it's orange so the reason is at this
point this is a red this is a red
herring
it's it doesn't exist very defining
accent color we can't we can't just fall
back to this
similarly with background red we can't
just fall back to back to background red
this is what we're stuck with and this
is what we have to use so because accent
color is defined with a cycle it becomes
equivalent to accent color initial and
since exit color is set to initial it's
the same as if it has never been defined
the second the second argument fallback
is not just used if the variable has
literally never been used anywhere it's
also used when the variable is
explicitly set to initial value because
it's the same thing as far as CSS is
concerned of course if we remove that
useless declaration now we get
transparent so I know that I'm speaking
about variables and some of you might be
thinking this is cool but what somebody
please think of browsers
like I couldn't use this in my project
my client will kill me like surely this
is not supported anywhere right you
might be surprised so CSS variables are
actually supported everywhere admittedly
you might not be able to depend on edge
15 but support is on every major browser
and for those of you that need to
support slightly older browsers there
are ways to get around it
for example the ad supports rule the app
supports rule is like the native version
of moderniser how many of you have heard
of supports a few hands up there how
many of you have heard of moderniser way
more hands okay you don't need
moderniser anymore
you can just use that supports it's not
just for CSS variables if you wanted for
example to experiment with CSS grid and
you obviously you can't depend on CSS
grid now you can use something like this
and then put all the grid rules inside
here and for CSS variables you can put
any pair of since every value is valid
you can put any value and any CSS
variable so I choose to use - - CSS
colon variables just because it look it
reads kind of nicely so any rules you
put inside here will only be used in
browsers that support CSS variables you
can also do the inverse you can put not
here and now if all the rules inside
here will only be used in browsers that
don't support variables I would strongly
advise you not to do that because if you
do that it's the the rules that will
actually be used are those are in
browsers that don't support variables
and support that supports which is kind
of a smaller set like I ate wouldn't get
these rules but if you do it in this way
every browser that supports variables
also supports app supports so you're not
limiting browser support in any way and
you could do all sorts of fall backs
that way and for those of you that
really like a not
cannot depend on fallbacks like you
maybe like a 60% of your user base is on
iaith or something you could still use
variables in smaller ways like let's say
you have some social media icons on the
footer and you want and you want like
the color to change when you hover over
them which is so much easier to do with
variables like that would be okay to
fall back to gray in ia like no nobody
would blame you for it this is the
support for app supports this is why I
told you don't use not always writes app
supports queries in a positive way so
those of you that are familiar with LA
with pre-processors like sass and less
might try to do something like this so
here notice that we have 33 in both of
these so that this div has the same
proportions as our viewport here 33% of
the viewport width and 33% of the
viewport height and let's say we want to
abstract away this percentage to a
variable so we do this and then how are
we gonna use this percentage here you
might try to do something like this and
notice that it's not working and those
of you that have used three processors
will be like what the hell why is this
not working so the reason it's not
working is that the browser sees this
basically as this it sees the the the
variable as a separate token you cannot
compose one token from a vary from two
variables or a variable and something
like variables are always separate
separate tokens you cannot have a color
for example where half of the color is
in a variable unless it's a separate
token unless it's in a function so does
that mean we cannot do what we wanted no
we can do what we wanted but it will is
very common with CSS it will just be
very long so to do what we wanted we
will need to use calc and then we
multiply our variable
with 1vw I'm sorry
and here with 1vh it's terrible but it
works notice that if I change this it
updates just fine so some of you might
wonder especially those of you Larry
that are especially allergic to
duplication good for you so you might
wonder okay what if I said 30 VW here so
that I can at least save one calc and do
this and then here surely I can divide
by one VH
so you might try something like this it
should work right you can see it's not
working however you would be right to be
confused it should work the reason it
doesn't is that when we defined calc
calc came before CSS variables and that
means it also came before the invalid
that computed value time concept that
didn't that was not a thing back then so
since we couldn't say there are some
cases where this becomes invalid at
computed value time everything had to
make sense at parse time so when we
divide by a length we don't necessarily
know if it's zero and that might result
in us dividing by zero in some cases so
what we did was we said you cannot
divide by lengths period you just can't
you can only divide by numbers so as a
result when when your variable is a
length you cannot go to anything else
you cannot do anything else with it if
you have a number like a pure number you
can go to any unit by just multiplying
with one in that unit if you have
something with a unit you cannot go to
the number you just can't there's no way
to do that in CSS right now so that
takes us to our 6 take away use
variables for pure data not CSS values
even if you think you
never gonna need the pure number chances
are you'll be proven wrong
so guard against it some of you might be
wondering at this point how many of you
have used CSS animations excellent most
of you how many of you have wondered how
these two work together during this talk
okay I expected a few more anyway even
if you hadn't wondered about this now
maybe you are so there are two ways to
use variables in keyframe in in CSS
animations the first one the first
question would be does the VAR function
work in key frames so let's try to do
that we can have a color one which is
our first color and the color two which
is our second color and we can go here
and replace color one and then we can go
here and replace color two and you can
notice that it still works just fine
so the VAR function works just fine in
animations but if you wondered at all
about variables and CSS animations you
probably weren't wondering about this
you were wondering what would happen if
I try to animate a variable like what if
I use a variable in multiple places and
then I just run a CSS animation over the
value of that variable what would happen
then so I'm gonna refresh to the slide
okay
to reset it and then I'm gonna define a
background the background color is the
value of the color variable and then I'm
gonna go here and change this to a dash
dash color notice anything where's the
animation there's no animation anymore
where did that happen so if we look at
the spec it says CSS variables can even
be transitioned or animated yay but
since the UA has no way to interpret
their contents meaning the UA doesn't
know what you really have there could do
you have a color do you have the length
like what could you possibly have in
those variables they always use the
at 50% behavior that is used for any
other pair of values that can't be
intelligently interpolated meaning if
the browser cannot figure out how to go
from value a to value B this is what you
get and with variables the browser can
never figure out because it doesn't know
what you plan for these properties so
the seventh takeaway is that CSS
variables plus animations equals
chocolate ice cream but wait there is a
solution in the near future sadly the
solution is in JavaScript which is not
ideal like it controls the CSS thing why
would it have to be in JavaScript but
that's how it is so you can register
your own properties and you can say what
the syntax is what values you expect
where in this case color values and you
can also say like the initial what's the
initial value whether it inherits so you
don't have to use that trick so let's
run this and let's see what happens see
now it works now it's just as smooth as
it was when I was animating background
color so yeah it's in the future it's
not quite here yet but you can
experiment with it in Chrome it's behind
the flag so actually CSS variables plus
animations equals love but in the future
some common use cases so the most basic
of components is probably a button but
everything I say applies to pretty much
any kind of component whether it's
defined via web components or some sort
of framework or you're just including
some library some CSS basically this
applies to any component you can imagine
so here we have a button and we have a
themed version of the button with a
class of pink and this is the CSS for it
this is the CSS defining the styling of
the component and this is the CSS
defining the pink theme now
that there's a lot of repetition here
how can CSS variables help us let's see
so I can define a color variable and
then set color based on that and I can
replace all instances of black with that
you can see it still works the same when
I hover I wanted the background to be
the to become the border color and the
text color to be white still works the
same but you might be wondering okay so
how did variables help us here okay we
can change it one place but we have the
same amount of code not in the themes
though the good thing is that now we can
delete this replace this with dusters
collar and delete this entire rule and
any other pseudo classes or special
cases anything like we can just delete
it this becomes the only thing needed to
theme our component and it still works
the same but the best thing is not the
reduction of code it's not the reduction
of duplication the best thing is
encapsulation it's weak I can change how
this very house this component is styled
and you that cups that have used it and
themed it don't need to know anything
you can just update your CSS file for
that component and you get the new
styling you don't need to change the
single thing in your code let's say I
decided instead of this abrupt
background change I want to do a
transition so I specify a transition one
second book shadow cuz I'm gonna do this
with box shadow and instead of
background I use box shadow 0 offset 0
blur 1 M spread and in sets so that it's
inside the element and now I get this
styling and notice that I also get it in
the themed component and I also get it
in any theme component I won't like I
could even style one like this and it
still works just fine and I don't need
to know anything about this change so
the nice takeaways that CSS variables
and enable theming independent of CSS
structure which I think is hugely
important and it also works with web
components by the way CSS variables
peers inside shadow Dom Brown boundary
you might have noticed so here I have to
set the value of color to a default
black in this case but I out there in
the wild you wouldn't want to do that
because your selector would not just be
button your selector might be some
complicated string of classes or
something and then anybody seaming your
component would have to use higher
specificity than that you don't want
that so ideally you want to use the
fallback parameter but notice that when
I do that there's a lot of duplication
like I had to repeat this three times
and probably way more in a real
component of course I could do something
like this and then I could go here and
do this but it's kind of horrible right
so what can I do instead I can define my
entire this entire thing in a variable
like let's call it color D or something
ugly like that and then here I just use
color D and here as well and here as
well and I just don't tell anybody about
it
I just don't mention color D anywhere in
my documentation I just say if you want
to style this component use - - color
and color D is based basically becomes
private by convention which might make
your skin crawl especially developers
but this is how we had private variables
in JavaScript for many many years so CSS
finally got there so a fantastic way is
that the fault default values are
possible yes I just coined the term
default default values and you do it
like that another huge benefit of
variables is responsive design you don't
have to override the ton of rules you
can just define a few crucial variables
and they just change let me get out of
full screen mode and I'll show you that
if I change this resize this window yes
finally so you can see that if I go
beyond like less than a thousand it just
changes automatically
so obviously in a real use case you
wouldn't just have one declaration
because here it's less there's there's
less of a point but you could you could
use gutter in tons of places for padding
for margins for even line height all
sorts of things and you just don't need
to override it in one place and it just
changes so xi takeaway is that CSS
variables make responsive design easier
too now after some common use cases
let's go to the cool ones
so clip path is a really cool property
it comes from SVG but in CSS it got a
much nicer syntax however it still needs
a prefix in WebKit and in the past we
used tools like prefix tree on
autoprefixer I even wrote prefix free
but these days you don't need these
tools you don't have that many prefixes
to use we're moving away from prefixes
but there's still some leftovers so
WebKit clip path is one of those
leftovers sonic if since we only need
like a very like very few prefix
properties we could do this trick we
could we could use a variable instead of
the property and then set both
properties to that variable so only when
that variable is set will we actually
get a clip path notice this so I'll try
to do a diamond here so 0 % horizontally
50% very claim and then 50% horizontally
0% vertically 100% horizontally 50%
vertically it's getting there and 50%
horizontally 100% vertically yay it's
there I always worry at that point so
and I could use this anywhere I could
use it in all divs but only used on the
inner divs I could say block one look
one day like I can just use it like a
normal like like pretty much the same as
the clip path property actually that's a
bit of a lie I can almost use it like
the clip path property except in one
case I cannot animate it
there's even with CSS not registered
property
there's no way to declare syntaxes this
complicates it so there's no way to
animate this variable but if you don't
need animation that could be a good
alternative
so the twelfth takeaway is CSS variables
enable you to set multiple properties at
once
you can also subset CSS properties and
pre fill some of their arguments for
example here I want to have a property
that there's the same thing as
box-shadow
but I don't have to specify a color it
just it pretty fills Rebecca purple as
the color and notice that I can use this
exactly the same as box shadow it has
only all the arguments work the X offset
the y offset the blur they all work but
the color is prefilled
it's always purple in fact I can't even
override it I cannot say right here just
becomes invalid because now it has two
colors so the thirteenth takeaway is
that CSS variables let you create single
property make sense
sadly you can create multi property make
sense which is what we really want but
it's a step there
programmers might be familiar with the
term function carrying it's kind of like
that also we could create our own
lunkheads in a way so here
it looks it like a lot of code but you
might notice that most of it is
repetitive I'm setting a lot of
variables for different components of
box-shadow and then I'm setting box
shadow to the values of these variables
and if I have to leave one of them
without a fallback in this case blur
because otherwise every element would
basically have a shadow so to get the
shadow I need to define box shadow blur
at the very least I'll set it so maybe
10 pixels something bigger and then I
can define a color let's say blue and
now I can say block 1 hover and I can
only override the color notice that when
I'm hovering the color is red I didn't
have to repeat any part of the box
shadow it functions like a long hand
like a short hand
so the 5th 14th takeaways that CSS
variables enable you to create custom
long hands and in some cases you can
even create your own properties in a way
so here I've set the the before pseudo
element of every element to the value of
the prepend variable which will only
which will only have a result if the
prepend very variable has a name and
since variables inherit they also
inherit inside their pseudo elements so
I can do things like this
and I can apply this to anything or just
the inside ones and so on
it works like a normal CSS property no
need to type an entire pseudo element so
CSS variables also enable you to define
your own properties in some cases I mean
it's a that's a little bit of limited so
CSS variables since they are native part
of the web platform they interoperate
well with every other web platform
technology like SVG or JavaScript let's
look at an example in SVG how many of
you can't code SVG even a little bit so
quite a few ok so I don't expect you to
understand tire SVG here this is the
important part the two irises in the two
eyes so I have some CSS here and notice
that if I change the CX here from about
25 to about 75 I can get the eyes to
look in different directions but 25
pixels and 75 pixels that are a little
arbitrary so it would be nice to have a
variable that actually means something
like a variable that ranges from 0 to 1
for example so I could do that like I
could have a calc function with 25
pixels which is the minimum plus 50
pixels which is the difference
multiplied by the value of our variable
and now I can just change the variable
from 0 to 1 which is much more easier to
understand
so CSS variables plus SVG equals love
now see my favorite part CSS variables
plus JavaScript the good thing is that
we already have JavaScript methods for
getting and setting CSS properties and
since since CSS variables are just CSS
properties we can use these existing
methods so we can use get property value
on an element style those of you who
don't write JavaScript don't worry I'll
go through like I don't have a lot of
JavaScript code and I'll go through the
entire thing
so there's get property value to get the
value of the property on the inline
style you can also get the you can also
get use the same function on what get
computed style returns
to get the computed style so you can get
the value regardless of where it comes
from it doesn't always need to be in the
inline style and you can also set it on
the inline style via a set property same
the same methods we would use for any
other CSS property they work with
variables too so our first example we
are setting to CSS variables to the
value of of the mouth of the cursor
basically to a percentage of the of how
much the the cursor is moved
horizontally and vertically so we get
the coordinates and with the we divide
by the width of the viewport inside a
mousemove event listener similarly with
the vertical one and then we set two
properties if we if you're using my word
it can even be as small as that and be
just in the HTML and let's use this
mouse x and Mouse Y property so here I
have a fixed radial gradient it's fixed
in the center but I could do something
like this I have a hundred percent x
mouse X and now I move my mouse and it
changes and I could also do the same
vertically and I move my mouse and the
center of the gradient changes and I
could even go and change how this
gradient looks and I don't need to
change anything in the JavaScript this
is especially
when you have separate teams writing the
JavaScript and separate teams writing
the CSS this means that you don't have
to go to the JavaScript developers and
pester them every time say can you
change this and they're like oh I can't
stand your designers we always change
your mind well now you don't have to you
just tell them to code the they you
write some JavaScript to set the
variables for the like pure data that
you need and then you can do whatever
you want in the CSS in fact these
variables don't even need to be purpose
specific remember this we could change
this and use this mouse X variable and
now it changes as I move my mouse I
didn't even have to think of this use
case when I coded that when I wrote the
JavaScript that sets Mouse X it just
works
for because it's it's generic enough
that it works for any use case something
I've often wondered wanted was to be
able to set the value of to style and
input based on its value you can do that
with a little bit of JavaScript here
we're going over all the inputs we're
setting a CSS variable to their current
value then we also add an event listener
that says when they change update this
variable called - - value so here we
have a very basic slider just an input
type it goes range with some basic
styling and this gradient is fixed but
we want it to change when we change the
variable so we can change this the
static 50% to something more dynamic
like 1% multiplied by the value and now
I can I can move the slider and the
styling changes obviously many most of
you can make it much prettier but you
get the idea also it's very common to
have these days especially to have
different styling as you scroll the
container and you can't do that with
pure CSS so with the help of variables
you can do it with the minimum amount of
JavaScript just basically these five
lines you go over all the elements that
have a given class scrolling in this
case and then you attach an event
listener that says every time this
element is scrolled
date this - the scroll variable - the
percentage that it scrolled so here I'm
getting the maximum scroll and the
current scroll and I'm getting the ratio
and setting it as that variable so here
I'm gonna change this to be dynamic
instead of 20% I'm gonna make it depend
on the scrolling so I'm gonna do calc
again a hundred percent multiplied by
the scroll variable and Oh multiplied
and now when I scroll you can see what I
get
and again the good thing is that I can
now change the styling and I don't need
to change the JavaScript let's say I
just want the progress bar in the top
now like this let's say I want to change
the colors make maybe make this red in
this white I don't need to change
anything I could even I could even
radically change the styling I could go
here let me take this so I don't have to
type it again and let's set the
background color to and HSL color
something like this and then I'm gonna
modify the hue to 360 x scroll now when
I scroll I get different colors it's
super silly it's the it's the most
ridiculous demo ever but I love it so
yeah you could even do that so what is
our last takeaway CSS variables are a
revolution for separation of style and
behavior there is a very big movement
these days for moving CSS the JavaScript
just because there are so many
JavaScript developers that don't want to
deal with any other language so they're
trying to like move everything to
JavaScript and sometimes you ask them
for arguments and they tell you well
JavaScript just gives you more
computation like some calculations you
just can't do in CSS like sometimes
you're styling depends on your data or
like you wanna do a square root of
something so now you have all the
computation of JavaScript you can use to
have a
to set variables and then all your
styling can be where it belongs in your
CSS and you don't need to do it no no
more generating gradients in CSS no more
generating like long lists of
declarations in CSS in sorry in
JavaScript you don't need to do that
anymore just set a variable and then
move everything else to the CSS so these
are the the the two versions of the spec
the first one is the stable version
second one is the most current version
always this applies to pretty much every
spec you have a URL like the TR which is
the most stable version you have the
draft dot CSS WG or GUI or URL which is
like the most current draft and that's
all I had
thank you I have stickers by the way
just find me and ask don't be afraid to
talk I I love it when people come and
ask me questions and like talk like
don't don't be afraid I don't bite so
gracias thank you very much
[Applause]